on va faire un vrai ou faux franck
dubosc puisque ont été pêchés plein
d'infos sur les réseaux sociaux à surfer
sur le net
vrai ou faux franck dubosc a changé sa
première couche en travaillant dans une
crèche
oui bah oui c'est évident mais oui
c'était d'envié ma vie ouais en 2009
lors d'un hommage à votre soeur
puéricultrices et la couche était
sacrément bien remplie franchement dieu
bénisse le tiens moi c'est très dur
parce que changer une couche on va au
bout d'un moment on s'y fait avec les
siens avec ses gosses mais quand c'est
pas le sien c'est la merde des autres
sets c'est dur à
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
organisée comme je fais propre pays ne
sont jamais ceux des autres il ne
supporte pas c'est pareil on perçoit le
cas très belle analyse tout lé bien ou à
peu près mais un ennui n'arrive jamais
seul et après les larmes aux rires de
crédit ce à quoi les petits grains
olalalala temps mis l'année que je
redoutais cette coque s'est engagé dans
l'armée et un moment donné on lui dit
mon gars ça y est tu parles
au début je faisais ça pour frimer et
bien on donnait là il se retrouve en
terrain croit beau monde y assure le
montre pas que taper un nom mais si voix
et les faïsses en fait moi aussi je sens
votre repas trappeur de ma vie dit elle
il sent que j'ai peur ils sont tous
coups a raison mais c'est ça bastien
déjà changé une couche
oui vous savez que j'ai jamais fait
j'avais jamais changer les clauses de
vous inscrire vous connaissez leur
prénom quand même c'est cool toi avec
moi il
ils sont là c'est vrai regardez
l'exemple du perray droit comme les
enfants sont là qu'ils les élèves pas là
alors si vous êtes venus je le voulais
qu'on savait encore rien dire pendant la
crise en occupe franchement entre deux
flèches tirées à vous avoue ouidah non
non il l'a fait à manger surnom bon ok
bah oui bah oui oui oui oui je le
voulais je leur fais à manger et manger
en tout cas
[Applaudissements]
car les enfants mangent les enfants
conçus après voilà il m'arrive de faire
un clip voilà ce que c'est vraiment
important qui a fait toujours kim ces
trois capitales et non c'est comme ça
mais bon c'est toi qui as fait à manger
ou pas autrefois mais il ils ont mangé
où ils ont pas mangées maman a passé
l'essentiel parce que non mais c'est
vrai quoi mathieu régale je constate que
vous avez déjà changé une couche
j'ai changé une seule fois pendant sa
faisait après saison voir comment cette
fois une couche aussi s'adresser pour un
chroniqueur y oppose deux mois une
mission regarde mais voyez bien qu'ils
arts vient de la fête foraine à la gagne
un colis pour les besoins d'un sketch
francs que c'est déjà mis une trompette
dans le rectum
rock est à l'occasion du festival juste
pour rire détiennent une trompette dont
les fesses alors on n'a pas retrouvé
l'image de la trompette c'est vrai on a
trouvé seulement sur le cs est la même
mais c'est la suite c'est quand on se
retourne exactement c'est à dire on à la
pizza devant on avait en est allé
jusqu'à j'ai pu chanter vous les femmes
qui à un moment donné il ya un an monte
de trompette mais c'est à dire on
n'osera pas le faire à et en inde comme
inscrire une trompette comme ça qui est
accroché dans la rue et on est face au
public
c'est diffuser la télé tout ça est très
sérieux et honnête et juste avant de
triompher dans le fait par le fait pas
on le fait passer c'est pas possible
et tu sais quand vous les femmes vous
les femmes et tuchan venir le ta ta ta
ta ta et est ce que je me répondait ce
que je me retourne pas s'est retourné il
ya l'image
moi je sens femme plus personne vous
choisi renouvellement enfin on serait en
mai
et mangent les autres
oui ce
[Applaudissements]
chez cos franck dubosc et stéphane
rousseau avait une part de pizza bien
sûr benjamin griveaux l'a fait avec une
part entière les shérifs
vrai ou faux franck dubosc a été
surnommé kikito oui sa première petite
amie espagnol qui avait crié cliqué tout
petit aux angles moyens sous la boue la
raison mais oui c'était sa première amie
fayolle qui avait crié qui tout petit
aux enfants bammer et un peuple qui sait
ça franck francky qui quittent aux
dérivés n'a rien à voir et cette raison
pour non non non non c'est une connerie
et que j'ai jamais vu monsieur mais ma
mère m'appelle encore qui tourne c'est
gênant oui la pratique et tiki toa
loketo il adore quelqu'un avait encore
les répondeurs téléphoniques je rentrais
à la maison tu c'est avec un ep nous
coach à l'eau qui tombe c'est génial ça
trop mignon franche est génial vrai ou
faux
comme valérie bénaïm franck dubosc que
tu toi george clooney puisqu'il a joué
un podologue dans la série urgences et
non mais où le sait à chaque fois que tu
meures où j'adore ce passage que séries
tu as joué quand même dans la série
culte highlander et oui voilà
ouais ça c'est ma fille tu se fait
entendre et ses passions ses érections
exactement mais là tu joues et michel le
bourgogne highlander gsm monde contre la
honte va s'arrêter voilà c'est de
l'espoir à je suis sérieux quand je joue
là mais je sais je suis en train de
mener une carrière américaine de garder
franck dubosc il est là bas il a
toujours été là regardez
[Musique]
iam michel de bourgogne tient le sommet
mais l'effort grec soit on a envie de
rigoler en fait nommer son retour avec
le casque et une envie de rigoler et
quand je lève les péladan la suite tu
sais on va faire un combat je lève les
pl est trop lourde
el basri au fond lors d'un tournage dans
la forêt canadienne
franck dubosc cph attaqué par des
centaines de bibitte 2008 des baby baby
baby baby ski s'est pas attaquée par des
bibittes
ouais c'est des petits gris bout seibert
c'est tout ce que de moustiques la beta
cheuvreux alors et tu t'es fatigué par
des mythes bas attaqué en avait partout
donc mois de juin au canada dans les
forêts y en a partout et si c'est tout
sur tout le problème
si en espagne c'est comme ça que ça
pique au dessous le jean 1 mais j'étais
attaché basse et salimata chez mc que
j'avais les mains les mains et les
jambes attachées c'est un sketch
toujours avec stéphane rousseau il me
transporte dans la forêt comme ça et je
sais tu es un substitut peut pas de
grave et je relaie la wii je devenais
très très méchant qui ne vais pas
attaquer par débit
[Rires]
avec son tout petit mais il ya tout
l'état est sûrement ça dérange personne
les chiffres livrés ou faux franck
dubosc qui pensaient pour que pour faire
humoriste il fallait être petit et gros
tessier bon bah ça qu'ils ont tout mon
nom en avant des brousseau de plus en
plus en plus avec gad elmaleh est beau
mais d'air elle est magnifique j'adore
müller avec nous je dis pas la grosse
rigolade bien sûr alors oui c'est vrai
c'est semoun qui vous a convaincu en
vous disant même si ton physique n'est
pas drôle tu peux te lancer dans le
stand-up
oui j'avais pas moi je serai enfin petit
c'était pas petit et gros mais savoir
qu'à leur physique de comique parce que
les comics madame on est pas mon époque
c'est coluche c'est elle qui avait bruit
il qu'ils étaient donc c'était le
physique du rigolo on va dire c'était
pas forcément ni groen et métaphysique
de rigolo moi j'avais un physique de
entre les deux jeunes premiers même
assez bons pour faire les beaux pas
c'est moche pour faire les moches
j'en veux le jeune premier un peu un peu
fadasse et donc c'est pour ça que j'ai
commencé à jouer là-dessus à faire le
mec on soir à faire le dragueur
je me suis dit s'il faut que je me moque
de moi faut que j'aille versa vers vers
ce que je représente physiquement mais
un peu en dessous le truc un peu de
pacotille quoi le sénat cessera
pacotille donc j'espère ça j'ai fait ça
mais effectivement non sinon je pensais
que je pensais et puis on a c'était la
réalité les humoristes étaient plutôt
avait plutôt des visages
c'est vrai tout cas pas entièrement vrai
parce qu'elle m'aimait michel leeb et et
humoriste et les paillettes plus tôt
mais j'aimais bien sûr alors les shihri
vrai ou faux le fils de franck dubosc
aimerait que son père face de la
chirurgie esthétique pour ressembler à
quilly à demba pays ont des vraies c'est
vrai c'est un vrai bon c'est vrai ça eh
bien regardez c'est une vidéo très drôle
qu'on a vu sur un spa avec votre fils
rôle à ça
je bats je rajeunis mon visage je me
fais une nouvelle tête en fait tu vois
hélas après j'ai acquis joujou changes
cfc me dire ça si vous souhaitez vous
venez de faire la chirurgie vous aimez
rire semble acquis vous autour de la
table franchement si on pouvait tout
changer mais oui johnny depp son père
est épaté pas à temps il ya déjà les
bras les jambes des caraïbes vous êtes
les mêmes arthur a mais franchement je
le jure franchement c'est vrai gilles
lellouche j'aimerais alors franchement
tu es pas content c'est vrai depuis leur
sang mais oui alors je sais pas qui tu
ressembles s'acquitte aimerait
ressembler à jean louis lemay gili
l'exemple que quand tu parles pas pardon
mais ses pattes inquiétez pas c'est bien
quand tu pars de pas très beau quand tu
vieillis
bah du coup certains chats il a de plus
en plus beau qu'il ya d'autres ici bas
autour de la table d'un regard des beaux
mecs fait danser à brega
il fait des fouilles excuse moi tu veut
pas la paix après eux